le 7 avril ce sera certainement une des
circonscriptions de l'île de montréal en
tout cas à surveiller verdun sa femme
quinzaine d'années que le parti
québécois souhaite prendre cette
circonscription de la dernière fois
j'avais passé très proche et la
circonscription de froid françois-henri
gautrain qui avait remporté par 537 voix
donc pour le parti libéral
il a quitté depuis il avait d'ailleurs
prédit lui une victoire du parti
québécois verdun c'est une
circonscription beaucoup de plus en plus
multiethnique à peu près 28 30 %
d'anglophones y vivent ces
l'île-des-soeurs beaucoup plus aisés
donc et verdun sur la terre ferme classe
moyenne des poches de pauvreté
importante
les candidats jacques daoust est une des
vedettes du parti libéral ancien
président à la tête d' investissement
québec
lorraine pintal pour le parti québécois
directrice artistique et directeur
général du théâtre du nouveau monde à
québec
benoît arich est candidat pour la cac et
rosa pires pour québec solidaire
j'ai rencontré jacques daoud et lorraine
pintal ce matin à verdun sida ou bonjour
bonjour quand c'est bien vers de vous
conseiller cette église à certains
quartiers et ni si oui le feu c'est rare
ça qu'une qu'un nom un peu connus se
présente un quartier où il est né quand
même ouais bah écoutez moi catalogue
proposé ça y avait certains côtés
étaient disponibles et je tenais à
verneuil parce que je lui dise
je dois même cinq ans
c'est important moi aussi je veux que ça
soit le libéral date et heure
puis les balles ok mais il ya un fonds
libéral ici important dans verdun parce
que ça peut changer penser je pense que
oui kaki cette année ah oui parce que
madame pintal a déjà fait lorraine
pintal
première question pourquoi pourquoi ce
sous là en ce moment en politique vous
avez une belle emploi j'avais répété
occuper pas mal au dos et après fin de
deux ans d'engagement au sein d'un grand
théâtre comme des terrains du nouveau
monde on sent le besoin de rayonner plus
largement dans l'engagement pour le
citoyen va se faire du théâtre c'est ça
aussi c'est s'engager c'est défendre des
causes alors que en politique
là c'est vraiment à l'échelle du québec
un appel de madame marois que j'admire
qui est rassembleuse qui ont une
formation politique assez exceptionnel
faire partie de ce mouvement de cette
marche qu'on enclenche et depuis les
derniers du mois vers l'idée d'un pays
d'un québec qui va devenir un pays c'est
très enthousiasmant votre moteur aussi
c'est la question nationale si ces
révolutions se répand solitude c'est un
du moteur parce que le service aux
citoyens
ça fait aussi partie de mes
préoccupations et l'indépendance
culturelle cette partie de mes
préoccupations quand on parle
indépendance il faut aussi décliné et il
ya la dépendance économique la
dépendance au niveau de la société la
dépendance identitaire et la dépendance
culturelle
j'apprécie beaucoup madame pintal
je pense que ça nous ferait une très
bonne ministre la culture
je n'aime vraiment pas les libéraux mais
probablement je vais voter miller
pourquoi parce que je suis un peu
inquiète de certaines choses que
j'entends avec lui
je racontais historiquement libéral mais
ça a été très serrée la dernière fois
henri françois gautrin vraiment c'est
fait chauffer comment vous abordez cette
campagne c'est votre première expérience
de ma première expérience je la bonne
façon assez assez simple finalement
c'est que je pense qu'avec un programme
qui tient la route on est capable
d'aller chercher l'électorat qui nous a
fait défaut un peu mais quand même pas
de façon dramatique
il ya des gens et puis quelques jours
qui dit là attention jacques parizeau
est sorti les souverainistes ont été
choisis ont été séduits ont été
agréablement surpris de l'engagement de
capelado je parle zouk écrivait hier
enfin on a reconnu la souveraineté au
sein des débats
est ce que vous êtes de cette année dans
le fond parlons-en clairement aux gens
plus tant mieux
la souveraineté ou jamais est écarté du
centre des débats par pauline marois ce
qu'elle dit c'est que l nous sommes en
campagne électorale
nous allons voter pour un gouvernement
majoritaire je l'espère du parti
québécois
par la suite elle ne déclare je ne veux
pas bousculer les québécois je suis
d'accord avec cet avis et en temps et
lieu nous allons créer un livre blanc
sur l'avenir du québec consultez la
population et par la suite en temps et
lieu lorsque la population sera prête
on ira vers le référendum que l'on soit
le gagnant il faut qu'il soit gagnant
alors il faut des conditions gagnantes
pour réussir le référendum d'accord mais
dans un comté comme verdun le vote la
cac
quand même eu 19 % il ya déjà un an
windows
est ce que ces gens là quand on part la
question nationale selon vous mon pote
plutôt être tentés de voter libéral que
de vous a pu croître et va y avoir un
mouvement probablement vers les deux
parties je sens qu'il y a pas ce que je
consulte la progression se fait du
porte-à-porte je me promène sur la rue
wellington à l'île des soeurs ayant des
cas qu'est ce qui nous dit souvent
l'hiver le pq parce que c'est le pq qui
répondent le mieux à ce qu'ils attendent
d'un gouvernement
j'avais commencé à parler aux citoyens
peu de quoi vous parlez gens des c'est
amusant parce que des grandes
préoccupations ici c'est l'hôpital vous
en avez entendu parler de verdun qui
croule - le vieux mec mais la chose qui
a été fascinante sur ça c'est que j'y
suis né voyez-vous et et à cet hôpital à
l'époque mes parents tenaient ce que ce
que je vienne au monde dans un hôpital
note parce que on avait personnel dédié
pire et moderne on encore le personnel
dédié
il faudra s'en occuper il ya des chants
bio carte passionne dans laquelle n'y a
pas de salle de bain il faut vraiment le
dire mais qu'est ce qu'un engagement
précis n'encense pas écouté il y aura
des engagements publics
moment où on parle russe doit y sommes
de santé vous servir partie on est très
systémique dans notre approche mais y
est clair qu'on peut pas avoir un
hôpital comme celui là que de location
important et ne pas se préoccuper de
l'hôpital vous avez dit j'ai fait du
porte à porte de quoi les gens vous ont
parlé c'est un peu un livre de nos
préoccupations comme la réfection des
rues et l'âge et les rencontres avec
monsieur jean françois parenteau le
maire on va discuter de ces dossiers là
jusqu'à la ruelle verte l'économie
l'emploi la rue wellington et la
promenade wellington est un projet
fabuleux parce que vers des nouvelles en
pleine transformation et des commerçants
s'unissent pour que la rue wellington
représente une force économique que les
gens de l'île des soeurs ils viennent de
manière fort autour d'une grande rue
marchand oui au programme oui et on
parle d'un hôpital l'hôpital est crucial
c'est il va falloir qu'il y ait une
expansion une modernisation de l'hôpital
et seul le parti québécois a donné son
appui
ça fait des années que sous le parti
libéral ce projet là est en dormance
moi j'en veux aux soldats
ok
au fait qu'est ce qu'un certain c'est
pas riche ya beaucoup de locataires ici
on est au cou de l'enfant et salue sa
part des mouvements sociaux ou qu avec
les deux gros party le parti québécois
partis libéraux vont ferons pas ça non
on dirait la qui condamnera à quoi songe
à coeur et qui y quelles épaules sinope
qui était de la misère ne loge bas on
est en train de changer
il y aura 125 140,1 le quand la ville a
été fait bien sûr on est en banlieue
morin est maintenant en rêvant du
centre-ville de montréal à l'eau quand
les maisons qui sont à l'effet de leur
vie utile sont reconstruites bayonne
tentation de reconstruire des chaussures
beaucoup plus cher ça pourrait changer
le tissu social il faut pas se perdre un
sévère d'un avec ses spécificités et
pour moi ce sera une préoccupation les
ayant été investissement québec on est
capable de faire des courbes de
vibrations qui sûr je pense ici au bord
vraiment que ce modèle
comment la campagne nationale le
bouillonnement depuis une semaine sur
des vues les dirigeants sur la
souveraineté le référendum la réforme du
fédéralisme
parce que ça s'ajoute un conti chez les
gens passion prévu une population pour
qui c'est su que ces choses le jour où
on sait que les personnes plus âgées
sont très occupés mais moi ce que j'en
entends parler beaucoup plus et
d'emplois ici d'un terre-plein on veut
des emplois au nord on en apprend un
milieu industriel ici on est crevé à ce
détail votre commerce de proximité et on
a surtout des hôpitaux avec le décès
l'hôpital de verdun le gars au chs d ici
on doit d'essayer des séries ça c'est
employons sont importants et ce qui
préoccupe les gens et ces substrats et
logements sociaux ici il ya des gens
auraient beaucoup de jeunes familles qui
ont déménagé il ya pouvoir d'attraction
dans verdun en ce moment il ya beaucoup
de jeunes familles qui viennent nous
voir mais il ya un niveau aussi de
pauvreté et pour madame marois elle
annoncé 7500 nouveaux logements sociaux
sur l'île de montréal avait aussi une
priorité accordée au sud ouest six de
ces choses-là dont les gens vous parlent
et non pas du grand rêve nécessairement
qu'il souveraine et seront de faire du
québec une t on vous parle de choses
bien qu'on les deux c'est assez
intéressant des discussions comme on
sait que j'ai en face à face il ya des
gens qui vont me parler de souveraineté
qui m'ont parlé de nos valeurs de notre
identité et qui sont des souverainistes
convaincus dans l'âme et les autres qui
vivent des problèmes du quotidien wave à
aller voter l'adapt j'ai mon parti pour
lequel
donc j'attends et des six vous savez
quoi elle d'habitude véloce capable de
faire des films de froid raconte la
charge
je lisais lorraine pintal ce matin
jetons ou su ormes articles dans la
presse qui peut diriger le tnm vous êtes
news bien déjà en train de vous
remplacer karim wade bercy du oui mais
si vous aussi vous rapportez pas vous
retourner et nrj un congé sans solde qui
me permet de retourner au tnm d'assurer
une transition
lorraine pintal bonne fin de campagne à
verdun on va suivre ça le 7 avril et
beaucoup d'intérêt ce même chemin de
campagne
merci ça